[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
locale voici les titres de ce jeudi 30
janvier montigny-le-bretonneux
accueillez les jeunes pour sa
traditionnelle soirée des métiers de
l'orientation le rendez vous se tenait
hier au pôle jeunesse de la ville sur
place exposants conférences et
animations pour faire ses choix de
filières et formations sans stress à
montigny le bretonneux justement
l'ancien conseiller municipal
d'opposition pierre déjean emmènera une
candidature de gauche aux élections
municipales
il est la tête de liste de montigny
solidarité 2020 la partie dédiée au
scrutin à la fin de cette édition
enfin le nouvel an chinois a débuté
depuis samedi dernier pendant quinze
jours l'année du rat et célébrer des
festivités sont organisées samedi dans
la commune de verneuil sur seine sous
l'égide notamment de l'école le dragon
bleu son président sera en plateau et
puis on vous donne aussi quelques idées
de sorties à faire pour ce week-end
[Musique]
cette visite pour commencer ce journal
les différents représentants de l'union
européenne dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui ursula von der leyen david
solier charles michel se sont réunis à
la maison jean monnet situe à bazoches
sur guyonne lieu symbolique de la
construction européenne et visite des
présidents de la commission du parlement
et du conseil européen pour débattre des
enjeux actuels de l'ue eux et défis
géopolitiques transition climatique et
numériques future conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe une déclaration
commune sera rendu demain vendredi
collégiens lycéens et étudiants avaient
rendez vous hier en fin de journée à
montigny le bretonneux pour cette soirée
et des métiers et de l'orientation
organisé par le pôle jeunesse de la
ville
la manifestation avait plusieurs
objectifs informer mais aussi rassurer
les plus stressés aurélie rond et
marylène yapi chesneau réfléchir sur son
avenir professionnel à la lueur des
bougies
c'est le concept proposé depuis 2012 par
le service jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux différents pôles
d'information ont permis aux élèves mais
aussi à leurs parents d'y voir plus
clair
c'est très compliqué en plus nous on a
quittés
il ya déjà un moment donc on connaît
moins les écoles les filières
d'aujourd'hui dans l'informatique par
exemple beaucoup de nouveaux métiers
sont créés et quand on connaît pas donc
c'est pas évident pour nous de pouvoir
les aider les aiguilles souvent il ya
une part d'angoissé autour de
l'orientation le fait d'être accompagné
par des professionnels
ça permet de dédramatiser un petit peu
et de prendre le temps
au programme conférences pour mieux
connaître les dates clés de
l'orientation stands de découverte des
métiers et de formations possibles sur
notre territoire les plus indécis
pouvait effectuer des tests
d'orientation en ligne
je me dis que si je sais pas trop quoi
faire assez vite va pour mes études
sérieuses être compliqué autre
inquiétude pour les élèves et notamment
les terminales les inscriptions depuis
la semaine dernière sur parcours sup la
plateforme d'admission postbac
parce qu'il faut le redire c'est
aujourd'hui vous devez faire un choix
qui est difficile mais par rapport à qui
vous êtes maintenant peut-être les 6,5
10 ans on ne serait plus la même
personne n'aurait plus mêmes objectifs
et du coup vous aurez le droit de
changer concernant parcours sup les
élèves ont jusqu'au 12 mars pour saisir
leurs voeux dans l'actualité également à
versailles ce matin le lancement du
deuxième carrefour des entreprises
c'était à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines organisée par
le rotary club versailles parc une
quarantaine d'entreprises étaient
présentes pour rencontrer les acteurs du
territoire lors de ce rendez-vous tables
rondes conférences étaient proposées
tout au long de la journée avec
plusieurs thèmes le financement le
management l'innovation technologique ou
encore les investisseurs un
rassemblement pour échanger et se
rencontrer entre entreprises mathilde et
demi pour les propos recueillis une
entreprise c'est un corps constitués qui
a l'une un enjeu social aussi puisque
c'est une entreprise qui permet de créer
la valeur
donc c'est vrai qu'on a des
problématiques de répartition naturelle
dans toute société mais sans création de
valeur y'a rien de possible derrière
donc c'est un lieu d'échangés l'objectif
c'est que c'est un lieu tournée vers
l'entreprise vers des professionnels
puisque aujourd'hui on a un excès
réservé limitatif aux professionnels
mais ces professionnels ont besoin de se
connaître de trouver des partenaires de
trouver des clients donc le sujet de la
journée c'est vraiment la rencontre et
les changes
ce samedi verneuil-sur-seine sera à
l'heure asiatique le nouvel an chinois
se déroule à partir de 17 heures défilé
dans les rues de la ville pour célébrer
l'année du rat au programme lions et
dragons de lumière notamment on en parle
a décrit frédéric malet bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le pré
10dans de l'école le dragon bleu qui est
derrière l'organisation de cet événement
avec notamment les commerçants de la
ville et aussi la commune de verneuil
verneuil sur seine
déjà il n'a jamais été question pour
vous d'annuler cette manifestation c'est
qu' à paris le nouvel an chinois a été
annulé en raison de l'épidémie mondiale
du corona virus il a pu en être question
parce qu'en fait si tu as un problème
sanitaire
un problème sanitaire passera toujours
au dessus de toute façon des loisirs de
l'amusement et l'animation
cela dit ce n'est pas si on peut annuler
une manifestation pour des raisons
objectives et non subjective donc on a
attendu que le gouvernement en fait
donne les instructions pour savoir est
ce qu'on continue les manifestations ou
papa que le nouvel an chinois puisque
c'est un événement franco-français à
verneuil-sur-seine on n'accueille pas de
chinois
les chinois ne viennent pas encore à
verneuil sur seine pour le nouvel an
chinois peut-être un jour mais pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là donc c'est
un événement purement français qui ne
nécessitaient pas du tout d'être annulée
après on sait qu'on a pensé quand même
alors forcément une ambiance
particulière de solidarité pour un rein
c'est un nouvel an chinois extrêmement
particulier très particulier très lourd
mais à la fois on était réconfortée par
le les messages nombreux qu'on a reçues
de chine pour nous dire fêter le faites
le on ne peut pas le faire on ne peut
pas se déplacer d'habitude c'est 450
millions de chinois qui bouge là ils ne
peuvent pas bouger ils sont cloîtrés
chez eux mêmes la ville de zhengzhou
aujourd'hui vient de fermer ses portes
donc c'est considérable
faites-le pour nous et du coup c'est ce
nouvel an chinois effectivement à
verneuil devient vraiment particulier
très émouvant
les enfants de l'école des écoles la
source la garenne vont chanter on faire
une chorale en chinois vont reprendre
l'hymne e2020 qui est chanté partout en
chine par les enfants et les enfants de
l'école dont le chanter et en plus une
ça va être transmis puisque ça va être
filmé et retransmis il ya déjà
aujourd'hui trois chaînes chinoises qui
nous ont contactés pour diffuser le film
à tous les enfants douran qui qui vont
voir qu'en france et partout ailleurs
des gens je pense à eux et fête le
nouvel an chinois et pourquoi c'est
important de nouvelles ont justement
pour les chinois quelle symbolique il a
cédé festivités qui est dure deux
semaines mais le nouvel an chinois est
née 2600 ans avant jésus-christ vous
imaginez ça devait donc 4600 en gros que
ce nouvel an existe c'est un moment
fondamental qui dure 15 jours et même
plus après avec la fête des lanternes
c'est un moment mais tellement
considérables que dans les familles
chinoises
tout est bouleversé on va même chez le
coiffeur pour vous dire que dans chaque
détail c'est une nouvelle année on
démarre tout on prend des bonnes
résolutions
on prie pour qu'il n'ya pas de mal a dit
imaginer la souffrance des chinois
actuellement qui pris normalement une
nouvel an chinois quand il n'ya pas de
maladie et qui leur arrive ce virus qui
paralyse tout en fait sur place donc les
chinois sont très malheureux on pense à
lui en ce moment très fortement et toute
cette soirée va être consacré au nouvel
an chinois avec à la fin même une ive
ailleurs une flash mob de tai-chi-chuan
la première fois que ça va se faire
une flash mob de tai-chi-chuan qui va
être un moment un petit peu de
de recueillement pour penser pendant
quelques minutes au peuple chinois
il a feint un lâcher de lanternes
lumineuse qui va s'envoler vers le ciel
et vers la chine ne symboliquement bien
sûr donc voilà pour le programme c'est
une évidence de le proposer chaque année
c'est un événement qui s'installe
maintenant à verneuil-sur-seine je vais
y arriver si belle en chinois le oui oui
il faut le pour moi je suis je suis vous
l'avez compris je suis un amoureux de la
chine
évidemment il faut le il faut le
continuer il faut rappeler déjà bon que
c'est on vit le monde est petit
aujourd'hui vers le monde est un grand
village
donc aujourd'hui la chine n'est plus un
pays du bout du monde dont on parle pas
ou dont on parle mal énormément d'idées
reçues circulent sur la chine quand on
connaît les chinois ce sont des gens
adorables charmant moderne très moderne
et donc il faut effectivement désormais
compter sur cette culture et en parler
au moins une fois par an et là ça se
passe exactement comme dans les autres
comme comme ça doit se passer un nouvel
an chinois à savoir que vous avez une
ville qui décident de fêter le nouvel an
chinois qui le fait
grâce au soutien des commerçants qui
bien sûr les commerçants sont très
impliqués dans les projets et donc là
les commerçants de verneuil notamment
sont extrêmement impliqué dans le projet
pour attirer le dragon attirer les lions
en faisant des offrandes en dévorant etc
pour que le lion le dragon vienne vienne
devant chez eux et apporte la prospérité
et puis le troisième élément qui est
fondamental verneuil a de la chance pour
ça c'est d'avoir une école de kung fu
parce que toutes les prestations sont
des prestations extrêmement sportive et
en chine
à chaque fois dans toutes les villes de
chine on appelle l'école de kung fu
locales pour faire allégeance à l'école
le dragon bleu en l'occurrence voilà
pour cette présentation je rappelle que
le nouvel an chinois avec sur scène
c'est ce samedi à partir de 17 heures
dans les rues de la commune toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site
notamment de l'école le dragon bleu mais
aussi sur le site de la commune de
verneuil sur seine merci frédéric palais
merci à vos présidents de cette école le
dragon bleu de verneuil sur seine est
depuis le 15 janvier six installations
ont pris place au sein de la commanderie
à elancourt elle questionne sur la
notion de genre et es7 une exposition
collective qui met en valeur de jeunes
artistes mélanie poker
photographies peintures lumière et
nouvelles technologies et es est un clin
d'oeil à l'écriture inclusive
une exposition en partenariat avec une
association d'étudiante et ria qui
soutient les arts numériques et les
artistes émergents de c'était d'avoir un
bastin un espèce de petit panel de
différents types d'expression dans l'art
numérique ça c'est une chose et aussi la
pertinence de la réponse enfin pas la
pertinence mais en tout cas la façon de
répondre à la question
l'oeuvre enfin le jean influe-t-il la
création de l'oeuvre ou la réception de
un appel à candidature a été lancé six
installations qui interroge sur le genre
ont été sélectionnés des heurts qui
pousse à la réflexion
[Musique]
parmi elles cette création permanente de
caspar ravel
c'est une oeuvre qui est créé par une
intelligence artificielle en direct donc
c'est performatif sait jamais la même
chose
elle elle joue et donc elle compose en
direct tout le temps vous avez la même
chose et pareil elle compose l'image
avec du glitch arthon que c'est l'art du
bug informatique
une exposition qui incitent à la
discussion entre les visiteurs et qui
est visible jusqu'au 8 mars à la
commanderie ya elancourt
[Musique]
mélanie peau qui à présent avec moi sur
ce plateau bonsoir de la rédaction de tv
soixante dix huit pour découvrir
quelques rendez-vous loisirs de ce
week-end le premier mélanie va être très
musical c'est aussi l'occasion peut-être
de découvrir les talents de demain
puisque à magny les hameaux la maison de
l'environnement accueille la 5e finale
du tremplin des voix c'est le concours
de chant de la poire en scène c'est le
dernier palier à passer pour les 20
candidats c'est un concours qui prend de
l'ampleur
250 personnes se sont portées candidates
et 140 ont été auditionnés alors face à
un jury de professionnels mais le public
aussi vote
et oui le public a son mot à dire celui
de la salle mais aussi ceux qui vont les
regards des deux chez eux car le
concours va être diffusé en direct sur
youtube et nouveauté cette année c'est
aussi sur notre antenne le concours
débute ce samedi 1er février à 20h pour
un rendez vous plus intime il faut
plutôt se rendre à versailles
ah oui alors là on va partir plus
exactement au musée lambinet quatre
étudiantes de l'ue vs qui ont réalisé un
partenariat avec le site culturel pour
un événement alors on part au xviiie
siècle au coeur d'un hôtel particulier
le musée lambinet les étudiantes vont
vous qu'on vous ont concocté un
programme avec des visites un récital
avec des instruments d'époque un atelier
en partenariat qui l'osmothèque ou aussi
des jeux d'époque et on écoute les
précisions de l'une des étudiantes
on essaye de faire venir un public varié
après en fait les étudiants c'est pas
forcément le public qui sera le plus fin
qui est le plus habitué à fréquenter le
musée lambinet donc le but aussi c'est
de faire venir des étudiants et présenté
voilà un nouveau format tu pourrais plus
peut-être les intéressés l'événement est
gratuit
après il faut payer là le tarif d'entrée
au musée
donc c'est 6 euros et puis en tarif
réduit ses 4 euros donc c'est le 1er
février de 14h à 18h30
14h à 18h pardon à versailles donc au
musée lambinet alors si vous ne savez
pas quoi choisir pour une fois les
horaires vous permettent même de
profiter des deux rendez vous à votre
choix grégory merci mais la nuit comme
d'habitude on peut retrouver d'autres
idées de sorties dans le magazine 7,8
loisirs vous en êtes aux commandes et
c'est à retrouver sur tv 78 après ce
journal
[Musique]
mais d'abord la partie de ce journal
dédié aux élections municipales qui
approche je vous rappelle le premier
tour et au programme le dimanche 15 mars
alexandra rosetti maire sortante de
voisins-le-bretonneux depuis 2014 se
présente pour un second mandat nous
l'avons suivi dans sa campagne le
reportage est signée marie ligne piccino
et marne et manon varaldo alexandra
rosetti mer depuis 2014 et candidat pour
un second mandat construction de
l'écoquartier amélioration de la
circulation et de l'espace public parmi
ces projets de lui tiennent à coeur
une salle des fêtes un lieu dédié où les
gens puissent faire c'est leur mariage
dans un anniversaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui voisin a beaucoup de
salles de quartier mais tout est
enclavée dans des résidences qu'on a un
projet de maison pluriprofessionnelle de
santé dans le quartier de la grande île
et
ça c'est un enjeu important parce qu'on
a la moitié de nos médecins généralistes
qui partent à la retraite
cette maison pluri professionnelle de
santé serait à l'emplacement de l'ancien
leader price avec seize logements à
l'étagé pour présenter ses actions
opération de porte à porte pour
alexandra rosetti par quartier halte à
la bretonnière on vous donne voilà un
petit document sur ce qu'on a fait dans
votre quartier c'est un quartier qui a
quelques commerces également à l'entrée
qu'il convient d'essayer de préserver au
maximum puisque les une boulangerie qui
a disparu par exemple alexandra rosetti
est allé à la rencontre des habitants
l'occasion de revenir sur certains
travaux de voirie et de faire connaître
les futurs membres de la nouvelle équipe
plus les racines des arbres on va dire
des fois les voitures exemple était
dedans c'est très bien parce qu'on peut
évidemment l'échangé avait directement
et le maire et puis le conseil municipal
madame le maire c'est la première à
passer l'échangé direct et on a le moyen
de dire ce qu'on pense
une réunion publique aura lieu le 2 mars
à 20 heures à la maison des associations
du plan de l'église à montigny le
bretonneux un duel à trois listes se
profile pour ce scrutin pierre déjean
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la tête de
liste de montigny solidarité 2020 une
candidature de gauche pour vous qui êtes
ancien conseiller municipal ans dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux vous
êtes aussi engagé dans l'associatif
locale vous avez siéger au sein du
conseil municipal de 2008 à 2014
pourquoi vous vous engagez dans cette
campagne des municipales
pourquoi parce que il faut que la gauche
soit présente sur ring
montigny-le-bretonneux tout simplement
et au regard de ce qui se passait dans
les veaux début de l'année il est apparu
que il y avait quelques difficultés de
ses côtés là et puis j'ai rencontré un
ami que je connais depuis quelques
années et qui de gauche aussi puisque
les clones labaki et président de la pop
secrétaire pendant de la section
socialiste de montigny et il m'a dit bon
écoute faut qu'on discute pour les
municipales donc haut la presse assez
embrouillée on s'est vu on a trouvé
quelques personnes en plus et puis de
fil en aiguille on a monté une liste
donc ça c'est important pour vous
défendre ses valeurs de gauche dans une
commune qui est plutôt
traditionnellement de centre-droit entre
calais les maires qui sont jeunes et
lance les dernières années si on défend
ses droits c'est vrai sur les mers
le conseil municipal bien entendu c'est
pas forcément vrai sur toutes les
élections il ya des élections où la
gauche était majoritaire et donc là il
ya un problème il faut au niveau
municipal aussi la gauche se trouve sa
majorité
et c'est ce que nous avons essayé de
faire alors si nice qui partent
finalement seuil avait des discussions
qui étaient en cours avec une autre
liste m qui est menée par un conseiller
municipal d'opposition il vient gas qui
a oui tout à fait et on a vu
de nombreuses réunions de discussion
pour savoir puisque ils ont un programme
qui est un peu serait même n'est que
nous mais là où il ya eu le
l'achoppement c'est effectivement sur la
qualification de gauche puisque ça a
posé des problèmes là on est d'aider des
discussions on avait trouvé qu'on a
commencé à trouver un terrain d'entente
et puis tout d'un coup au feu ce terrain
d'entente a disparu nous non pas
question de mettre la gauche nous on est
pas on se qualifie pas comme ça ils ont
choisi la division où ils ont choisi
ambitions qu'il recevra nice qui se veut
un peu plus ouverte pour votre liste
ouverte
oui mais ouverte vers quoi avait requis
on aura le clasico c'est l'agression il
ya des gens de plusieurs partis mais
aussi beaucoup de gens et la plupart qui
ne sont pas mandat partie d'accord et
qui sont dans l'associatif ou dans la
fin de ce qu'on veut mais mais par
contre qu'ils ont effectivement qu'ils
partagent avec nous de fortes valeurs de
gauche et est justement est-ce que vous
revendiquez une investiture pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes ouvert à
d'éventuels soutiens pour cette élection
pas revendiquer d'investiture d'aucun
parti même ceux pour le ceux qui en sont
membres
par contre nous acceptons effectivement
les soutiens ça je dirais que chacun est
libre de ses choix
charbonnier est maître chez soi dit on
et bien si les partis politiques de
gauche veulent nous soutenir oui on
n'acceptera bien entendu mais nous ne
demandons pas d'investiture avant de
parler de vos priorités il y en a trois
pour cette campagne votre regard sur le
mandat qui va s'achever prochainement
celui de 2014 à 2020 avec comme maire
michel laugier d'abord qui est devenu
sénateur puis jean-luc ourgaud tout à
fait on a eu droit d'ailleurs à la
présentation de la candidature de ce
marqueur l'autre jour un candidat de la
majorité municipale compte des notes de
thau droite
un beau symbole scénario quand même de
bien fait et on m'expliquer que monsieur
abou avait pris monsieur logés comme
chef de cabinet et monsieur auger devenu
maire du monsieur logis et choisi
monsieur marcatté monsieur m'a 4
ambition de devenir maire henri dont on
attend avec impatience qu'elle est le
quel sera le nom du prochain sur le fond
du mandat sur ce qui a pu être sur le
fond c'est donc c'est plutôt de la
communication beaucoup de communication
ils sont très forts par contre pour les
réalisations c'est un peu moins un peu
moins on vous promener dans les rues de
montigny c'est pas nos propres été
exemplaire et un certain nombre de
locaux
public d'ailleurs particulier les
maisons de quartiers qui sont dans un
état lamentable
donc ils le disent beaucoup de choses
sur montigny la ville qui voit bien je
crois qu'il ya quand même de ce côté là
beaucoup de choses à améliorer pour ce
saut vraiment une ville qui nous avait
bien alors trois priorités
on va parler d'abord de la démocratie
locale comment faire partager justement
les citoyens les faire aussi participer
davantage à 7 alors démocratie locale de
ta feuille c'est une un problème auquel
nous avons à avoir à nous affronter
parce que la démocratie la participation
des choses des citoyens c'est pas
quelque chose d'évident
ne serait-ce que quand on regarde des
élections il ya beaucoup de citoyens qui
s'abstiennent donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose
un vrai challenge alors nous avons
d'abord décidé que les conseils de
quartiers seraient modifiées et
revivifié est par exemple c'est plus
qu'un symbole beaucoup plus que symbole
le président de la commission de
quartier sera élu élu par les membres de
le lan de la commission et non plus d
amener du désignés par le maire
je vais dire que ça c'est un exemple
mais on peut avoir aussi des commissions
sur un thème précis
donc on notera en place et puis quand le
thème sera clos comme la solution aura
été trouvée la pollution disparaîtra en
avoir une autre sur un projet autres
quelques-unes des pistes alors loïc
l'autre priorité deuxième priorité qui
est une valeur traditionnellement à
gauche mais que l'on retrouve
constamment maintenant un an cette
campagne des municipales c'est
l'écologie on ne peut pas faire ça
aujourd'hui presque quels sont vos
projets propres propositions parmi les
victimes on ne peut pas faire ça j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour indiquer que
notre liste
bien sûr s'occupera essentiellement des
problèmes tiny montas mais que nous
estimons que ces problèmes ne sont pas
indépendants de ce qui se passe dans le
monde
temps fort bien sûr et dans le monde
entier le problème de
2 du réchauffement climatique va toucher
le monde entier le monde entier alors
évidemment nous n'allons pas résoudre
nous à nous tout seul le cette question
là mais on a un certain nombre de choses
que l'on peut proposer sur visualisation
des bâtiments publics
encore une fois je vous reparle et
d'évêques maison de quartier parce que
ou des coûts certaines écoles qui sont
des passoires qui sont des passoires
nous allons avoir enfin nous allons
essayer en tout cas de mettre en place à
100 de cellules photoélectriques sur les
sur les soirs sur les toits et
d'ailleurs j'ai vu il ya quelques jours
sur un je suis plus ou sur un de vos
confrères écrit qu'une société avait mis
au point et c'était très intéressant des
cellules qui permettent de récupérer à
la fois l'énergie solaire directeur pour
transformer les précités et la chaleur
alors que aujourd'hui il ces deux types
de ce différend donc ça c'est une
aventure des déchets valorisés à porter
on va creuser de ce côté large de la
gambie
pour l'instant oui c'est bien de ça
vient de sortir donc je n'ai pas plus
d'informations que ça mais on va creuser
de ce côté là parce que d'abord un il
n'y a que les rénergie que l'on ne
produit pas qui ne pollue pas donc il va
falloir s'atteler à la réduction
drastique de consommation d'énergie
clairement on en a besoin et donc voix
pour cela il faut chercher tous les
moyens
d'abord de produire
de l'énergie sans avec le moindre effet
sur le changement climatique
et puis récupéré tout un tas de
d'énergie qui sont perdus et que l'on
pourrait utiliser un dernier mot en 30
secondes paris on arrive à la fin de
cette intronisation votre dernier volet
la solidarité oui la solidarité parce
que c'est du crois que c'est un élément
fondamental de la du vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui par exemple on a un peu
tendance à mettre des gens dans des
cases les jeunes les vieux les actifs
les chômeurs 2.5 et où on peut cumuler
plusieurs plusieurs cases et je crois
qu'il faut mettre ensemble les gens faut
lui faire rencontrer celles à base de
démocratie de citoyenneté
on aura l'occasion de reparler un de
votre programme sur cette antenne et je
précise aussi qu on retrouve comme pour
tous les autres candidats à montigny le
bretonneux dans les autres communes des
yvelines
votre agent date campagne sur le site
internet de tv 78 points comme merci
pierre déjean il est repassé en plateau
en tête de liste de montigny à
solidarité 2020 et deux autres listes au
moins seront également en cours celle de
laura merker candidat de la majorité
sortante signé montel et la liste m
conduite pour l'instant pour un bis par
un binôme avec le conseiller municipal
d'opposition vilain gas et caroline ce
chaos pour refermer ce journal direction
la commune de trappes pour connaître les
enjeux des élections municipales dans la
ville nationale 10 sécurité jeunesse
emploi et rénovation urbaine ont fait le
point le projet est dans toutes les
têtes depuis 20 ans longtemps au point
mort l'enfouissement de la nationale 10
à bien démarrer un chantier préparatoire
en 2019 le début aussi des travaux
d'aménagement cette année avec la
création d'un mur de protection et la
destruction du pont marcel cachin près
de la mairie prévue cet été
le projet comprend le dénivellement de
l' axe routier qui coupe la ville en
deux la création de trois plateaux
urbain et de deux points en entrée et
sortie de ville coût total estimé plus
de 95 millions d'euros
comme dans d'autres communes c'est la
sécurité qui est au coeur des
préoccupations des habitants trappe
touché par la radicalisation avec des
dizaines de départs vers la syrie par le
trafic de stupéfiants et par les
règlements de comptes entre bandes la
mort du petit moussa en 2015 avait
grandement ému
la ville fait partie des quartiers de la
reconquête républicaine identifiés par
l'état depuis plusieurs mois la police
de sécurité du quotidien est déployée
avec deux unités de patrouilles à pied
au contact de la population trappe ou la
moitié des 33 mille habitants à moins de
30 ans 25% au moins de 15 ans la
jeunesse est donc également un enjeu un
projet éducatif de territoire a été
défini et c'est un collège dit innovant
qui pourrait voir le jour sur place dans
les prochaines années
thématique dans la continuité répondre à
la problématique d'emplois dans la ville
où le taux de chômage s'élève à 19 % 5
points au-dessus de la moyenne régionale
25% de la population trappistes
vivraient sous le seuil de pauvreté
enfin trap est une ville qui a
énormément changé profitant d'un vaste
plan de rénovation urbaine de 350
millions d'euros les habitants veulent
encore plus de mixité dans le logement
de nouveaux projets de construction
pourrait voir le jour prochainement
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]